hey David how will the 15% primary
threshold affect who wins the Democratic
primary so there's another way I think
that what people are trying to get to is
is the 15 percent threshold going to
screw this candidate or that candidate
so there's a couple things to understand
in the Democratic primaries there is a
15 percent threshold where if you don't
get 15 percent of the vote you don't get
any of the delegates this is
particularly important in the bigger
states because in the smaller states
there are often so few delegates to go
around that besides the the sort of
momentum impact of it it's not really
mathematically that important to be
getting delegates from the small states
as long as you can continue justifying
staying in the race if but if no
candidate meets the 15% threshold what
the Democratic Party rules say is that
the minimum to receive delegates becomes
half of the frontrunner vote share so
imagine that you have a state where a
candidate wins with 14% of the vote
that's the plurality 14% and then you
know someone else has 13 and 12 whatever
it adds up to 100 if the winner has 14%
everybody with 7% or more delegates gets
delegates so that's in the rules but
let's put that aside for a second
because that's not the most likely
scenario in later states in really big
states you could see this become a
factor in the broader delegate math so
imagine that California goes the way one
recent national poll says imagine that
Biden gets 23 percent of the vote in
California Warren gets 18 and Bernie
gets 14 hypothetically right because
Bernie didn't get 15 percent of the vote
Bernie gets 0 which means that Biden
gets his 23 percent Warren gets her 18
percent it actually can go up once you
eliminate people sub 15 but ignore that
for now but the really important thing
about this is that Bernie and Warren in
this scenario have 32 percent a strong
progressive contingent
has more support than Biden but that 15
percent threshold could make it so that
the progressive candidates get
kneecapped and end up getting zero in
some states because one of them didn't
get to the 15 percent this is why I get
emails from people saying David at some
point shouldn't burn your war and drop
out because if they make it so that
neither or only one of them gets 15% and
the other ends up getting no delegates
as a result of that isn't it going to
help the establishment
basically Joe Biden win the answer is
yes but this is why it's good for the
early primaries to help one candidate
build momentum over the other my most
the most likely scenario for how this is
going to go is that after New Hampshire
after sorry Iowa New Hampshire Nevada
and South Carolina after they all vote I
think there is going to be a clear a
clear momentum advantage for either
Bernie or Warren as the progressive
candidates and I think that in the end
the one with the momentum is going to
take a significant lead over the one
that doesn't have it and this issue of
splitting the progressive vote will be
less and less of an issue as the
campaign goes forward I could be wrong
and if that doesn't happen then it is
possible that the progressive wing of
the Democratic Party will be hurt by
this but my expectation is that the
first four primaries will establish
which of the two progressives is going
to go the distance and that then you
will very quickly start to see support
coalescing around one or the other if
you think it won't go that way then I
want to hear from you either leave a
comment if you're watching on youtube or
send me a tweet at D Pakman we've got a
fantastic bonus show for you today with
producer Pat become a member at join
pakman.com or a patron at patreon.com
slash david pakman show to get instant
access to that bonus show